Transcriptor: Ester Julian
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En el chat familiar, mi hermano
que vive en EE. UU., puso:
“La próxima semana tengo
que regresar 3 días a la oficina,
estoy devastado”.
A él le encanta ir.
Lo que pasa es que tiene que manejar
el equivalente de Cartago
a Puntarenas ida y vuelta
por lo que preferiría ir
dos días, no tres.
Además los dejaron escoger los días
y es el único que va a ir los viernes.
Va a llegar allá,
después de esa manejada, se va a tener
que conectar virtual con el equipo.
Para él no tiene sentido.
Y esto no es un ejemplo único;
4 de cada 10 personas entrevistadas
están dispuestas a dejar el trabajo.
Y es que la pandemia va a pasar,
pero esa nueva perspectiva
de cómo son nuestras prioridades
y cómo queremos vivir es lo que queda.
Ya no queremos volver a rutinas
que nos dañan
y que además probaron ser innecesarias
para nuestra productividad.
como por ejemplo esa,
el desplazarse de la casa al trabajo
que ya estudios prepandemia habían dicho
que es el momento que más perjudica
al bienestar mental, emocional y físico,
provocando enfermedades y padecimientos
y robándonos de tiempo.
Quedarse desde la casa no solo beneficia
a esos con el privilegio de teletrabajar
sino también a aquellas personas
que se tienen que trasladar sí o sí,
ya que aliviana los sistemas viales
y de transporte público.
El 83 % de las personas indicaron
que quieren mantener
opciones flexibles de teletrabajo.
En esos mismos estudios,
el 69 % de las personas desean regresar.
O sea, que queremos lo mejor
de los dos mundos:
teletrabajo y presencial.
Y tiene  sentido.
Yo, por ejemplo, me visualizo entrando
a la oficina y saludando a la gente,
escuchando el bullicio y las risas.
Me imagino piropeando
y diciéndole a alguien “qué pelillo”.
Estoy ansiosa de ver caras conocidas
y saber de sus vidas.
Según las encuestas,
lo que más extrañamos son:
espacios colaborativos,
todo tipo de networking,
tener mayor visibilidad
y esas interacciones humanas.
Y es que si bien hemos mantenido
la productividad,
inclusive en algunos casos ha aumentado,
lo que ha sucedido es que se han hecho
estos hilos por equipo de trabajo
y eso afecta la innovación.
Es el perfecto momento para repensar
cómo usamos las instalaciones e inmuebles.
En vez de seguir creando
múltiples espacios individuales,
podemos predestinar esas áreas
y esos presupuestos
y crear ambientes más colaborativos
que sean más agradables
y que fomenten la creatividad.
Y que sirvan para todo tipo de uso
grupal y diferentes tamaños,
Que no solo beneficien a los colegas,
sino que además
sirvan para generar conexiones
más significativas con los clientes,
no solo a nivel racional,
sino emocional y sensorial.
Otra razón por la que queremos regresar
es porque el agotamiento digital es real,
que lo digan mis ojos.
Según cifras, el uso de plataformas
de comunicación virtual como Teams o Zoom
se ha más que duplicado.
En promedio, las videollamadas
están durando 10 minutos más largo,
o sea, se hacen eternas.
Estamos chateando 45 % más por semana
incluso fuera del horario laboral.
Hay investigaciones que dicen
que en el modelo híbrido
los niveles de agotamientos son más bajos
que 100 % presencial
o 100 % desde la casa.
La pregunta “¿dónde vamos
a trabajar después de la pandemia?”
se vuelve trivial.
Pero, “¿cómo aseguramos  que cada persona
sea productiva en cualquier lugar?”
Hay puntos de vista que hablan
de una correlación directa
entre sentirme optimista o pesimista,
energizada o agotada
y la abundancia de recursos.
Cuantos más recursos tengo a la mano,
más optimista y energizada me siento.
¿Se han preguntado cómo está su gente?
Volviendo al ejemplo de mi hermano,
el comité ejecutivo de su empresa
pasó de un modelo presencial
a un modelo híbrido, muy bien,
les dio cierta flexibilidad
a escoger los días, bien.
Pero le faltó lo más importante,
que es liderazgo con humanidad.
Liderando con humanidad, se asegura
que los recursos ofrecidos
realmente sean útiles para cada persona.
Y se comprende
que las medidas van a afectar diferente
a cada grupo de personas o a cada persona
y eso amerita flexibilidad.
Por ejemplo, la generación Z
que está entre los 18 y 25 años
reporta sentirse más afectada
por el aislamiento.
Por lo que podría pensarse
que el trabajo presencial
Sí, siempre y cuando no haya excepciones
como por ejemplo que alguien viva lejos
porque recordemos que
una de las ventajas del teletrabajo
es poder expandir la búsqueda
de talentos, ampliar el territorio.
Entonces, siempre
es verificar caso por caso.
El liderazgo con humanidad
se asegura de que cada persona
tenga los recursos necesarios
para poder ser productiva y saludable
donde quiera que esté.
Recursos como: autonomía,
apoyo una salud mental positiva,
equipo técnico y ergonómico.
Altos grados de habilidades digitales,
políticas de salud
y una auténtica actitud de solidaridad.
Ejercer el liderazgo
con humanidad no es fácil.
Requiere ser intencional y esfuerzo,
pero es good business,
es buena estrategia de negocio.
El 63 % de las empresas
categorizadas de alto crecimiento
han adoptado un modelo de fuerza laboral
productivo en cualquier lugar.
Además, el liderazgo con humanidad
aumenta la confianza a la empresa,
su sentido de pertenencia
y por lo tanto, su permanencia.
Y queremos el ahorro
de la baja rotación, ¿no?
Además, el tema de tener más mujeres
en puestos de liderazgo
es más relevante si se quiere acelerar
la adopción del liderazgo con humanidad
ya que comparten la empatía, la escucha
activa  y la generación de confianza.
Como dice la canción:
“lo que un día fue, no será”.
Ya eso de volver a la normalidad
ya no lo queremos.
Queremos un modelo híbrido
altamente flexible,
liderado con humanidad,
transformando la experiencia laboral.
Y por último, en un mundo tan complejo,
por no decir caótico
el crecimiento empresarial
va a depender de una fuerza laboral
productiva y resiliente
que lo que realmente necesita
es más humanidad.